so after being fired and and the whole
thing happening and AIG crumbling you
said you developed what you call an fu
attitude did that come naturally or did
you go through like a depression or a
mourning period we're really questioned
everything and then you rose up from it
or were you just your mind was made you
know what no more no more this corporate
world I'm done oh yeah I definitely went
through a mourning period um when I went
and it first started working at aig I
was like 22 or 21 22 no 22 you know
right out of college moved to New York
City got your wall street job and I was
working really hard you know while
should expect like 70 80 hour weeks you
know you're there very very late you're
in there in the weekends and after a
couple of years there i was like 'i know
what i am going to be doing this for the
next 10 or 15 years and I'm starting to
realize like maybe partly because I'm
female maybe partly because like I come
across young I could be spending the
next 10 15 years of my life working 70
or 80 hour weeks for somebody else to
get rich and make a lot of money and you
know and i'll always be sort of i don't
know i just sort of i got this
impression that like I it may have been
not so much hard work but maybe like
time that would allow me to move up the
corporate regs which is what my goal
would have been so I switched I switched
and changed situations I'm like okay I'm
gonna do this aviation thing I've been
working on it too so
I am finished my piloting certificates
and I started a small business and it
was at at airports and then again it was
like I felt like I was getting I
completely switched situations but it
was still getting friction for being
female it felt like so I'm like okay I'm
going to go get an MBA and then i'll
definitely be valuable to my family's
gas marketing business it's very
quantitative and so I stopped my flight
school but halfway through my education
when / I started working for the family
and then a couple years into that and I
knew always that my family was a little
bit traditional being in the Natural
Resources business but it was really
heartbreaking when sort of sexist
traditional values even came ahead of my
own personal welfare with my own family
you know with my own father with my own
uncle people who were supposed to like
care about you now you can understand
that people who don't love you and care
about you any type of you know societal
dynamics will come into play but when
your own father and your own uncle feel
that it really felt that way to me that
I
sort of a ripple in the all the sons and
then in the men's bonding and the men in
the boardroom controlling things so that
hurt me so much I was really
disillusioned and I finally yeah I mean
I finally allowed my uncle would have
fought to to fire me he said he was
going to take me out with handcuffs you
know like it was where wasn't quite that
bad but it was like he wanted to make me
quit I would it so finally it was like
I'm going to fire you so that was
devastating and it continues to be so
and I do think that the the documentary
aspect that I wanted to bring to our
story of course I the entertainment
value as a way to reach people but the
what I wanted to bring on a serious note
to the audience is I don't think I'm the
only woman who has ever experienced this
you know in their career and the authors
that we brought in to interview Lynn
Cronin and Howard fine had written a
book on on on women in the corporate
workplace and the paradoxes that exist
and sort of make it difficult for them
to get ahead and I felt like I'd
experienced that enough ways you know
feminism and inequality of the workplace
isn't like a huge issue these days and
it's somewhat I don't know somewhat sort
of looked down upon so but it still
exists and it's still discouraging so
that was sort of the intellectual
component that I really wanted to bring
to the documentary and into an audience
and say okay so we sort of found this
way to maybe combat that or turn the
tables to give ourselves a more level
playing field or maybe even exploit a
different aspect of of being a woman in
a commercial way and I don't know I
wanted to sort of bring that into
the conversation with a greater audience
because I mean it still exists out there
and it still needs to be addressed by
society why do you think society is
threatened by beautiful and smart women
why do you think that that's so it's
like almost if they're smart then they
have to almost look like men and then
that's okay but what about if they're
attractive then why is that scary you
know why does it I don't know exactly
because i think these types of
prejudices exist as much with women as
they do with men you know women want to
sort of look down on other women like
for instance my boyfriend is an MMA
fighter and their ring card girls at his
events and a lot of the girlfriends are
angry at the ring card girls and I'm
like why they're there they're simply
marketing themselves as women in a
different way and why would you ever hit
a woman for being beautiful why would
you ever you know despise another woman
for capitalizing on an asset that she
has especially when we are disadvantaged
in a lot of ways you know whether you
know everybody wants to address that or
nine we are dissing are disadvantaged in
the corporate workplace I mean there are
not the same number of women in the
higher ranks of corporations and as
there are men and if you we make 75
cents on the dollar to men's wages in
the country still and it isn't changing
so so why I don't know but it was
definitely a question that I wanted a
lot of people to think about and not and
people on the right people on the left
you know feminists and conservatives and
and and maybe women will support women
more when you bring stories like this
out that would be my hope
you